The debt limit crisis finally over.
This morning
on this vote, the yeas are 63,
the nays are 36.
The 60 vote threshold
having been achieved.
The bill is passed
with just days to spare.
The Senate
passing that debt limit deal
late last night
and preventing an economic catastrophe.
President
Biden is now set to sign the bill
and address the nation later today.
At the White House, Senate
Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
giving a thumbs up after the deal passed.
He's also been building this as a victory
for Democrats
House Republicans were ready
to take default hostage
in order to pass a radical hard
right agenda
that never could have passed
with the American people.
So many of the destructive provisions
in the Republican bill are gone.
This bill was a total rejection of what
the Republicans wanted
And look at the vote
that proves
that our strategy was the right strategy.
That strategy, though,
was rejected
by some members of his own party,
some Senate Democrats refusing to vote
to support that agreement.
We should never have been put
in this position to begin with.
This is about paying the ransom
to a bunch of hostage takers.
And that is not how
we should run this government.
It's not good
for the people of this country.
CNN congressional
correspondent Lauren
Fox joins us live from Capitol
Hill this morning.
So the debt limit deal ends up with
decent bipartisan support in the House
and the Senate.
What is the feeling there this morning?
Well, it's a coalition
that you probably are going to see again.
Erica, as the year drags on.
That's because you have
divided government here.
You have a House of Representatives
controlled by Republicans.
You have Democrats controlling the Senate
and the White House.
And I just want to go back
to the
amazing feat last night in the US Senate,
not because they passed that,
but because they were doing it.
So quickly.
They had about a dozen amendment votes
and one after another.
Chuck Schumer,
the majority leader, was keeping track
of how long each vote was taking.
I just want to tell the American people,
usually the U.S.
Senate does not move that quickly.
Typically,
it takes them about an hour,
sometimes even more,
to have a single vote last night.
They kept members on the floor.
They were trying to move through
about a dozen amendments
very expeditiously.
Finally,
they got there shortly before midnight.
But one thing that became very clear
last night,
this is a bipartisan coalition
you're going to see again
at the end of September.
Lawmakers are going to have to pass
their spending bills.
We also know
they have to pass a farm bill.
They made some assurances last night
that there could be another
supplemental spending bill for Ukraine.
So this is a bipartisan coalition
that is going to have to come together
on Capitol Hill again.
And again
because we're in divided government.
Erica, as we noted, we're going to hear
from the president later today.
But the White House
has actually been fairly quiet this week.
It seems like.
Yeah, but, you know,
one thing
that we certainly can hear this morning
are the sighs of relief
from White House officials,
not only because this legislation
averts a potential default
that could have come as early as Monday,
but also
because it really helps
to smooth the path for this White House
over the rest of President Biden's term.
That's because this bill incentivizes
Congress to pass regular government
funding bills by the end of the year
to avert a government shutdown
or face across the board
to defense
and non-defense
cuts of about 1% to the budget next year.
That's a major piece
that White House officials
have been stressing to me
as one of the major
benefits of this bill.
Now, listen, President Biden,
he put out a statement last night
hailing this as a major win
for the American people
and for the economy.
And he also said that America is a nation
that pays its bills
and that this vote proves
that this bipartisan vote.
He thanked the Senate majority
leader, Chuck Schumer in the Senate
Minority Leader,
Mitch McConnell,
for passing this bill quickly
and getting it through.
And he now looks forward
to signing this bill as soon as possible.
We're told that that could happen
as early as today.
But as you mentioned tonight,
President Biden will address
the American people
from the Oval Office at seven p. M.
This will be his first address
to the nation from the Oval Office.
Certainly something to watch for.
Jeremy, yesterday
we saw the president
take what appeared
to be a pretty hard
fall at that commencement
speech at the Air Force.
How is he doing?
We know he made a joke of it.
He made a lot of light of it.
But do we know how he's doing?
Well, the White House says
that he is totally fine,
that he
simply tripped over that sandbag
that was left on the stage after.
And we should note that
this came after
he shook hands
and saluted cadets for over 90 minutes
on stage yesterday,
hundreds of those cadets.
But the president did indeed
make light of it.
You can see how he's doing for yourself.
Take a look at
how he returned to the White House
last night.
He says he's
got sandbagged
And you see the president there
doing a little bit of a two
step there to show folks
that he's doing just fine.
That's how the White House is doing
and looks that way to fail
to set the sandbag shuffle.
We'll come up with lots of names for it.
Jeremy, Laura,
nice to see you about this morning.
Thank you.